[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
Elizabeth borne confronté à son premier
front syndical alors que la grève dans
les raffineries perdure et que le
mouvement s'était tendu à d'autres
secteurs comme l'énergie et les
transports la mobilisation
interprofessionnelle a été lancée par
plusieurs syndicats pour l'augmentation
des salaires et la défense du droit de
grève le secrétaire de la CGT Philippe
Martinez a déclaré dans le cortège
parisien qu'il y aura des suites la
bataille pour l'augmentation des
salaires et le pouvoir d'achat face à
l'inflation est au centre d'une bataille
politique que l'on retrouve à
l'Assemblée nationale et où est débattue
en ce moment même le budget alors quel
est l'ampleur du mouvement social la
question des salaires est-elle au cœur
de la préoccupation des Français et
fait-elle tâche d'huile ailleurs en
Europe cette grande sociale est-elle un
premier test pour Elisabeth borne et
comment finalement le gouvernement y
répond-il faut-il taxer ou pas les super
profits ou miser encore sur une
contribution européenne et bien on en
parle avec mes invités j'ai plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés Jean garrigue
bonsoir vous êtes historien également un
président du Comité d'histoire
parlementaire et politique votre dernier
livre Élisée contre Matignon le couple
infernal c'est chez Talandier bienvenue
à vous en face de vous Benjamin Coria
bonsoir bonsoir professeur de sciences
économique à Paris 13 membres des
économistes atterrées votre dernier
livre le lien commun le climat et le
marché c'est au lien qui libère à côté
de vous roselynefeuvre Charles du
service politique de France 24 bonsoir
Roselyne et puis on fasse Karina chabour
bonsoir Karina chroniqueuse économique
toujours sur France 24 ils ont donc
battu le pavé aujourd'hui en France on
parle de 107.000 manifestants d'après
les chiffres qui viennent de nous
parvenir du ministère de l'intérieur
c'était ça s'est passé dans 150 points
de rassemblement selon la CGT qui a
organisé cette journée avec les
syndicats FO solidaires et FSU à Paris
la manifestation a démarré à 14 heures
Place d'Italie des grèves ont eu lieu
également dans 11 centrales nucléaires
on va écouter Philippe Martinez et puis
quelques manifestants et en débat
ensuite
je crois que le point de rupture il est
franchi depuis longtemps avec le
gouvernement qu'on a qui a fait preuve
de beaucoup de
d'autoritarisme et de mépris envers à la
fois les grévistes dans le privé comme
les enseignants dont je fais partie quel
est votre revendication aujourd'hui
des pensions de retraite bien sûr
poursuivre l'inflation au moins sur
l'inflation quoi parce que depuis
l'inflation c'est
une catastrophe moi je suis tout
nouvellement retraité mais j'étais
fonctionnaire dans la fonction publique
ça fait 12 ans
sous le régime de Monsieur Sarkozy que
le point dentiste qui détermine le
niveau de salaire dans la fonction
publique il est bloqué oui le
gouvernement a plusieurs discours
il y a quelques semaines au début du
mouvement il disait qu'il y avait pas
avoir de problème de pénurie etc on voit
le résultat aujourd'hui
il est réquisitionné gré décideurs qui
c'est une attente au droit de grève il
essaye de faire croire qu'il y a pas de
grévistes alors que s'il y avait pas de
grévistes il y avait il y aurait pas
besoin de réquisitionner des grévistes
il suffirait de faire appel au nom
gregistes donc il ménage le chaud et le
froid parce qu'il sait bien aussi que le
mécontentement il est fort dans ce pays
autour de la question les salaires
Benjamin Coriat pour cadrer le débat la
grève on le sait a démarré chez Esso et
total il y a trois semaines d'abord
est-ce que vous avez été surpris et
est-ce qu'il y a un vraiment un problème
de salaire en France non j'ai pas été
surpris j'ai pas été surpris moi je
pense que ce à quoi on assiste c'est la
conjonction de trois choses si je peux
dire
bon il y a un problème de rattrapage
d'inflation et c'est vrai que on sort
d'une période on rentre dans une
nouvelle et j'ai presque envie de dire
on sait pas très bien comment faire avec
des niveaux d'inflation de ce type les
économies sont même été surpris par le
niveau d'inflation
oui enfin pas tous mais en tout cas oui
entreprise à ce niveau et au niveau
mondial c'est quand même c'était
inattendu voilà bon donc on a ça et donc
c'était sûr que ça allait créer des
séries de décalage je veux dire même les
les
accords qui ont été signés dans la
plupart des cas ils sont en dessous du
niveau d'inflation donc on a ce premier
problème là ensuite on a un deuxième
problème qui est le problème plus ancien
alors des bas salaires des petites
retraites qui de plus sont montés très
forts avec la question du covid et des
premiers de cordée il se trouve que les
premiers de cordée c'est les plus mal
payés bon donc ça devait revenir à un
moment ou un autre et puis la troisième
chose qui qui est dans ce climat si je
peux dire c'est cette question des
inégalités en particulier avec
l'explosion des dividendes enfin le cas
le cas exemplaire c'est total qui
distribue 2 milliards et demi de
dividendes après avoir refusé d'ouvrir
des négociations bon donc la conjonction
de ces trois choses là fait que bon on
est vraiment dans une situation
particulière Jean garrigue est-ce que
c'est ta nouvelle automne sociale et
l'ampleur de la grande sociale
c'est sûrement un nouvel automne social
ça c'est incontestable qu'elle ampleur
il va prendre assez compliqué de le dire
encore aujourd'hui me semble-t-il moi je
souscris l'analyse qui est faite des
trois courses j'en rajouterai une autre
qui est qui tient aussi à ce qui s'est
passé au moment de la covid etc la crise
d'accovide qui est mais qui est une
révolution culturelle en réalité qui est
ce cette nécessité ce besoin pour les
salariés notamment de participer
beaucoup plus aux partages des richesses
en fait je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
de très profond dans dans les sociétés
industrielles démocratiques en général
c'est ce cette volonté aujourd'hui de
changer un peu la donne c'est-à-dire sur
le partage de la valeur chez chez Total
où on voit bien que les dividendes sont
allés aux actionnaires ou
subsidiairement au PDG mais
pour moi la question du PDG c'est
symbolique c'est un symbole très mauvais
très très dur mais c'est pas quelque
chose d'important mais en revanche cette
idée si vous voulez que il faut remettre
un peu les cartes sur la table et
redonner au travailleur au salarié la
part qui leur revient cette idée là je
pense qu'elle est elle s'est
véritablement enracinée dans la société
française c'est parce que c'était pas
une idée nouvelle c'est pas une idée
nouvelle mais c'est quelque chose qui
avait un peu disparu en tout cas auquel
on pensait moins c'était moins au cœur
de la de la de la réflexion et même du
mouvement social depuis quelque temps
Roselyne premier test pour le
gouvernement borne on peut dire oui mais
j'ai envie de dire c'était les yujols
suspects que il y avait dans la dans la
rue aujourd'hui alors vous avez cité les
chiffres 107.000 en France et 13000 à
Paris quand on regarde si on compare
avec la journée de sur la vie chère la
marche de la vie chère de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est beaucoup moins cependant
ce qui ne veut veut pas dire que cette
manifestation n'est pas légitime elle
l'est légitime parce que depuis plus de
20 ans le salaire réel n'a pas à
progresser en France que de 1%. donc il
y a ce oui cette légitimité en revanche
se rattrapage dont tu as parlé
finalement quand il y a un peu
nécessaire et le sujet aujourd'hui c'est
de savoir si il va y avoir une extension
du voilà de la grève notamment chez EDF
et dans le secteur dans le secteur
nucléaire c'est ça qui est qui est
embêtant parce que dans le fond ça
donnerait les mêmes résultats que ce que
nous fait subir en quelque sorte
Vladimir Poutine alors sans esprit
polémique
j'ai envie de dire est-ce qu'on a besoin
de ça et d'un autre côté il faut marquer
le coup mais je pense quand même que
pour finir que
cette manifestation on sent bien que les
syndicats ont envie d'en garder sous le
sabot garder des forces vives parce que
dans le décor
il y a la réforme des retraites et qu'il
faut garder bien sûr du carburant ce
mauvais jeu de mots pardon pour pour ce
combat ce combat social et qui est lié
puisqu'on les entendait justement les
manifestants parler de la réforme des
retraites Karina justement Roselyne par
les salaires à l'instant comment se
place la France par rapport au reste de
l'Europe sur l'augment d'abord sur
l'inflation alors d'abord son inflation
effectivement elle a augmenté les prix
ont augmenté au mois de septembre de
6,2% sur un an c'est plus du double
qu'il y a un an sur la même période mais
si voilà on regarde les voisins
européens eux ils sont plus touchés par
l'inflation voyez l'Allemagne notamment
10,9% l'Estonie qui est nettement plus
dépendante du gaz russe 24,2% en dehors
de l'Union Européenne le Royaume-Uni
avoisine les 10% alors la raison on l'a
dit c'est que la France elle est moins
dépendante du gaz russe même si
actuellement on voit que plus la moitié
de ces réacteurs nucléaires sont à
l'arrêt et autre raison c'est que
maintenant voilà un an qu'elle a mis en
place ce bouclier tarifaire pour
plafonner les prix pour justement lutter
contre cette inflation et d'après
l'Institut national des statistiques si
elle n'avait pas pris ces mesures et
bien aujourd'hui l'inflation serait
supérieure en France de trois points
Benjamin bondir la France est finalement
pas la plus mal lotie en terme
d'augmentation des prix grâce ou pas aux
mesures gouvernementales ah oui oui
incontestablement je pense que le
bouclier
sur l'énergie a contenu
les chiffres globaux de l'inflation la
pauvreté d'après ce que j'ai vu n'a pas
augmenté mais les inégalités oui c'est
ça en fait le constat mais avant même
d'en venir à ça c'est très bien que je
veux dire le bouclier a limité
l'inflation il y a pas de discussion
là-dessus donc de ce point de vue c'est
une bonne mesure le seul problème c'est
que l'inflation forcément elle est
évaluée à un niveau très global mais si
on regarde les biens essentiels en
particulier des biens alimentaires
l'inflation elle est si on regarde ce
qui est beaucoup plus inquiétant d'une
certaine manière
l'augmentation des prix dans les
supermarchés dans les supermarchés
c'est-à-dire là où les gens
s'approvisionnent en vérité pour
l'essentiel elle est de 10% moyenne bon
donc je veux dire c'est bien d'avoir
contenu à 6 % mais ça peut cacher des
réalités notamment pour les bars revenus
assez différents donc un choc inflation
ah oui il y a un choc inflation et puis
surtout ce qui est embêtant c'est que il
faut trouver un dispositif de moyen
terme pour ça parce que ça va pas
disparaître la semaine prochaine donc
est-ce que ça veut dire des négociations
globales sur les salaires Benjamin
coriard global ou pas global je sais pas
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que il faut
que en tout cas les directions des
grandes entreprises
soit bien plus réactive et ouvre de
véritables négociations en ayant en tête
non pas parce que moi c'est ça comme
économie c'est ça qui me choque beaucoup
parce que on leur dit ok l'inflation
elle est de 6 on vous donc 3% et sous
forme de prime on vous redonne deux et
demi de ce qu'il faut que ça soit
temporaire parce que l'inflation sera
peut-être différent dans un ou deux ans
mais si vous réfléchissez comme ça la
hausse des prix elle est construite
durablement donc l'an prochain avec la
nouvelle hausse des prix il faudra
rattraper ce qui a été vous comprenez
c'est alors ça c'est un marché de dupe
et c'est pour ça que les salariés ont
beaucoup de mal à accepter
décompensation sous forme de prime parce
que la prime elle est provisoire mais
l'installation de la hausse des prix
elle est durable les trois ou quatre ou
cinq pour cent de demain c'est sur la
base de de 6% d'aujourd'hui après la
spirale inflationniste alors oui ce
problème donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
trouver des dispositifs
on se recontrente à une situation
nouvelle mais il y a des pays comme
comme la Belgique comme d'autres etc qui
ont trouvé des formes de
d'indexation souple qui n'ont pas du
tout conduit à cette spirale moi je dis
pas que ce problème n'existe pas je dis
qu'il existe mais pour autant il faut
trouver des formes dans lesquelles les
salariés sont pas obligés tous les ans
de recommencer à négocier pour la
nouvelle augmentation plus pour celle du
passé sinon on va jamais ressortir les
gens regardent ça vous rappelle un peu
vous qui êtes les citoyens de se plateau
ça vous rappelle un peu les années 70 ça
dès que ça soit les prix parler de
spirale à l'époque mais c'est pourquoi
l'idée qui a été agitée par Fabien
Roussel de l'indexation des salaires sur
les prix
échelle mobile des salles me paraît pas
une idée je suis pas toujours d'accord
avec Fabien Roussel bon ça mon opinion
un peu d'importance mais je peux en
l'occurrence il me semble que arrivé où
on en est aujourd'hui
y compris pour une durée déterminée ça
pourrait être une une des solutions
l'autre solution étant les accords de
branche il me semble que avoir lu qu'à
18h avait été signé un accord de branche
dans les industries de l'énergie
électrique
donc bon c'est c'est un début ce qui
s'est passé à total c'est qu'on a eu une
direction qui était vraiment qui n'a pas
été réactive c'est moi qu'on puisse dire
et puis un syndicat la CGT qui avait
intérêt pour des tas de raisons à jouer
un peu la surenchère et moi pour moi
alors ça c'est un symptôme aussi d'une
forme d'archaïsme du dialogue social à
la française il faut que les uns et les
autres
essaient de se moderniser un tout petit
peu dans leur pratique de négociation
parce que là c'est urgent
total Roselyne il y a un problème où
est-ce qu'il est le bouc émissaire total
alors
non il aurait pu quand même réagir
peut-être un peu plus vite il y a il y a
50-50% c'est 50/50 de responsabilité
chacun quand la CGT dit on fait la grève
pour des futurs négociations à venir
alors qu'on a même pas discuté et qu'on
coupe les vannes oui c'est pas c'est pas
mais d'ailleurs ils ont été entendus
force cette constater qu'aujourd'hui
toutes les ouvriers de Total ont obtenu
ce qu'il ce qu'il voulait cela dit ça va
oui
ils ont obtenu 7 % en global mais ça
recommence mais ça recommence
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas pouvoir faire
grève et éternellement attendez ça c'est
une autre question mais il faut pas dire
qu'ils ont obtenu ce qu'ils ont voulu
parce que ils n'ont pas obtenu un
rattrapage
pas seulement ça
n'est pas seulement ça pas seulement ça
le 7% c'est 7% de la masse salariale qui
est distribué
là-dedans il y a de nouveau une part de
prime donc pour certains il rattrapent
ce que je voulais ce que je voulais dire
c'est c'est bien que
les salariés fassent grève pour obtenir
ce qu'ils veulent cependant est-ce qu'on
n'est pas en train là de défendre aussi
une aristocratie de la classe ouvrière
qui a les moyens de se parce que leur
société fait des supers profits et les
autres vous parliez d'accord de branche
ou les accords en entreprise il y a des
entreprises qui sont trop petites et qui
peuvent qui n'ont pas syndicats et qui
ne peuvent pas et voilà qui ne pourront
pas faire d'accord et qui ne pourront
pas augmenter les salaires parce que si
ils augmentent les salaires ça peut être
la clé sous la porte donc c'est là la
difficulté
et puis il faut distinguer entre les
différents entreprises celles qui font
des bénéfices c'est une exception mais
c'est totalement emblématique du débat
sur la sur le partage de la richesse de
ce soir puisque total ce sont des
bénéfices records depuis un an et demi
mais effectivement parallèlement l'an
passé donc c'est plus de 8 milliards de
dollars de dividendes qui ont été versés
aux actionnaires c'est en gros la moitié
des bénéfices alors le groupe a certains
investi et continue d'investir un 14
milliards d'euros dont 3 milliards et
demi dans le renouvelable et
l'électricité la question c'est juste
est-ce que c'est pas trop dividende pas
assez dans le renouvelable c'est à dire
l'avenir et il y a la question
évidemment des salaires avec un Patrick
pouyanais qui s'augmente de 52% alors
c'est ça il y avait une baisse du
salaire là effectivement il se remet à
son niveau de salaire d'avant covid
covid période pendant laquelle les
dividendes ont continué à être versé aux
actionnaires donc voilà tout ça en terme
de symbole et de même d'avenir pour
l'entreprise d'investissement pose des
questions en fait ce qui se pose comme
question c'est lorsque effectivement il
y a des profits qui ne sont pas
forcément liés à une innovation ou un
investissement Benjamin Royat c'est une
situation de Han c'est une situation
c'est ce que c'est ce que John Ménard
économiste appelé des winfool profits
amenés par le vent bon donc je veux dire
que il fasse cet usage là de ces profits
AMD par le vent en créant une situation
de précédent qui a bloqué toute la
France dans une situation de tension
extrême parce qu'on s'est dit si total
refuse des négociations alors où on va
vous voyez le fait que vous avez tout à
fait raison
des petites moyennes entreprises et les
grandes c'est pas pareil mais si les
grandes commencent par donner ce signal
là qu'est-ce qui va se passer dans les
petites bon ça c'est un peu une première
chose la deuxième chose c'est c'est pas
parce qu'on est dans une grande
entreprise qu'on doit renoncer à
protéger son pouvoir d'achat je veux
dire sinon alors je sais plus où on est
donc si vous voulez la situation totale
moi je pense que c'est l'iceberg c'est
le sommet d'iceberg il faut discuter de
la profondeur de l'iceberg et dans la
profondeur de l'iceberg on trouve des
situations extrêmement différentes qui
ne pourront être réglées que par des
branches au niveau des branches ou par
des interventions de l'État sur les
minimum sociaux sur le SMIC etc il
faudra une palette de mesure on l'a dit
un petit peu tout à l'heure sur les
salaires toujours selon l'Insee depuis
le début des années 80 et bien
l'économie française a connu enfin et
dans une phase dite de modération
salariale c'est-à-dire que la croissance
des salaires et bien un ralenti ça
correspondait à une phase de montée du
chômage ça correspondait également à une
phase de désindexation des salaires sur
l'inflation et de moindre Reval de
moindre revalorisation du SMIC donc
aujourd'hui ou l'inflation est de retour
il y a évidemment ce phénomène de
rattrapage à côté de cette question de
partage des riches on rentre dans un
nouveau cycle ça c'est une certitude
mais pour répondre à la question
initiale si vous voulez mais c'est pour
rebondir ce qui a été dit le on est dans
une situation très différente entre des
grands groupes comme comme Total ou
manifestement il y a une redistribution
rééquilibrage qui s'impose et puis le
tissu qui est quand même le tissu
majoritaire dans notre économique les
petites et moyennes entreprises qui de
surcroît elles ont été victimes de la
grève de de la CGT à total donc ça
complique évidemment les choses pour
parler de la capacité du mouvement à
s'amplifier ou pas on se retrouve mais
dans une je l'ai pas inventé tout le
monde le dit dans une société
archipelisée fracturée et là on a des
intérêts qui sont divergents les uns les
autres en revanche le point commun c'est
cette volonté je pense collective
d'avoir des salaires qui rattrapent le
niveau de l'inflation et d'avoir un
pouvoir d'achat qui ceux qui soit à la
hauteur de des attentes ça veut dire
négocier négocier les entreprises
peut-être perdu un peu l'habitude de
négocier
elles ont perdu l'habitude les hausses
de saletés bon d'abord d'abord il y a
cette question de l'inflation on
répétera jamais assez que on est
confronté un problème qui est redevenu à
l'ordre du jour alors qu'il avait
disparu depuis fort longtemps et pour le
moment je veux dire j'ai presque envie
de dire on sait pas faire et les
entreprises ont pas la bonne réaction
c'est à dire que la bonne enfin celle
qui ne peuvent en tout cas les grandes
etc la bonne réaction c'est d'ouvrir des
négociations et de voir comment on fait
et la tentation de dire on règle ça par
des primes c'est pas la bonne parce que
ça sera encore pire l'an prochain comme
je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure bon donc
il y a des dispositifs un peu complexes
qu'il faut revoir bon voilà de de
comment qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la
productivité et qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
la valeur ajoutée alors bien sûr là il y
a un gros problème il y a un gros
problème et ça devient vraiment
l'objet d'un débat à l'Assemblée
nationale qui est extrêmement fort on va
écouter déjà Rosine vous avez interviewé
Sandrine Rousseau la députée en Europe
Écologie Les Verts il y a quelques
instants on va l'écouter
moi j'appelle à ce que la colère qu'on
ressent dans les discussions que l'on a
sur nos circonscriptions puissent
s'exprimer parce qu'en fait
j'ai vraiment l'impression et
particulièrement à l'Assemblée d'une
forme de rouleau compresseur du
gouvernement qui ne comprend pas qui
n'entend pas qui est enfermé dans son
mode de raisonnement enfin vraiment par
exemple on a fait avant les vacances non
juste après les vacances pardon on a
voté une loi de réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage cette loi va
mettre en précarité plus de personnes
pourquoi alors qu'on a un taux de
chômage qui baisse pourquoi le faire
aujourd'hui à part un entêtement
on voit bien qu'on est dans un bras de
fer entre le gouvernement et
effectivement donc à la fois les
manifestants les syndicats mais aussi
les politiques alors il y a un
gouvernement aujourd'hui qui n'est qui
est dans le fond
obligé de colmater c'est la seule chose
qu'il puisse faire alors sur total c'est
l'appel au réquisitions pour que les
Français puissent au moins prendre leur
voiture et avoir de l'essence il y a la
ristourne à la à la pompe les fameux 30
centimes je crois mais là justement on a
vu le changement de ton il y a quelques
jours Bruno Le Maire disait que ça
s'arrêterait mi-octobre et dimanche soir
la première ministre dit ben non ça va
ça va durer donc on colle le
gouvernement et dans le fond en train de
faire de la politique du un peu du
chewing-gum c'est-à-dire que on colmate
les endroits où il y a un peu de fuite
et d'un autre côté vous le disiez vous
et vous l'avez dit comme nulle part
ailleurs le gouvernement la force la
puissance de l'État a été là avec le
bouclier tarifaire avec pendant le covid
avec le crédit
voilà donc
mais aujourd'hui personne dans le fond
ne leur ne leur en sait gré de de
personnes ne reconnaît dans le fond
parce que c'est pas l'air du temps le
c'est comme si c'était normal que l'État
providence voilà mais tout de même sans
vouloir défendre ouvert l'avocat de du
diable puisque aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est montré du doigt c'est
sauver nous et des nous voilà il y a
quand même il y a quand même des choses
qui ont été faites il faut le souligner
à l'Assemblée nationale la question en
tout cas de la taxation des riches on
sait qu'elle embrasse littéralement le
débat les députés des nuppes mais de la
nuque mais aussi il le rassemblement
national et certains LR mais aussi au
sein de la majorité présidentielle vote
des amendements sur les super profils et
super dividendes lexit tax bref on va
écouter Olivier Véran le porte-parole du
gouvernement et on va voir justement
quelle est la ligne rouge du
gouvernement aujourd'hui vous savez nous
ne voulons pas augmenter les impôts des
Français et nous ne voulons pas
augmenter la dette et les déficits dans
notre pays en ce moment même le projet
de budget et prévoit par exemple de
baisser les impôts des Français 6
milliards et demi de baisse d'impôts
pour les gens qui travaillent pour les
classes moyennes et pour autant nous
respectons un objectif de retour
progressif à l'équilibre budgétaire donc
on voit bien le cadre fixé en tout cas
par Olivier Véran donc para Macron donc
pas de déficit donc on ne creuse pas le
déficit alors là on remet en place
encore le paradoxal
et à la fois exactement c'est le
paradoxe et en même temps on ne taxe pas
plus alors cette taxation des profits on
sait effectivement que même au sein de
la majorité il y en a qui serait prêt à
la voter en tout cas de voter quelques
dispositifs qu'est-ce qu'on fait il y a
eu un amendement du MoDem voté par une
partie députés
d'une certaine manière
symbolique aussi très important moi je
crie casse-cou là au gouvernement parce
que à ce à ce dans cette transition sur
la question de non pas de taxe pas
d'impôts supplémentaire ça va ça va
donner quelque chose de un effet
symbolique aussi comment dire je pervers
que au tout début quand ils avaient
supprimé un pot sur la fortune donc
c'est c'est quelque chose là qui est qui
qui à mon sens est un serait un signal
désastre d'ailleurs j'ai entendu Bruno
Le Maire qui disait qu'il n'allait pas
retenir
dans leur dans leur loi de finances le
le l'amendement du MoDem moi je pense
qu'il fait politiquement c'est à mon
sens une grosse erreur parce que ça
coûte pas si cher que ça c'est quelque
chose sur les super dividendes qui
devrait apporter 500 millions d'euros
par an selon l'institut montagne quand
vous choisissez par le modèle en France
quand vous faites payer les riches c'est
populaire et quand même alors va vous
répondre je ne sais pas des mesures pour
être forcément populaire mais je reste
cohérent en l'occurrence c'est que ce
serait cohérent avec la politique qui
réellement été faite parce qu'il y a eu
une protectrice une politique de
protection comme comme l'a dit Roselyne
tout à l'heure j'entendais juste une
incidence j'entendais la une enseignante
une collègue à moi qui disait ce
gouvernement nous méprise etc alors je
pense qu'elle parle peut-être du
précédent quinquennat mais la première
mesure du ministre de l'éducation
nationale Papin Diagne ça a été de
revaloriser les salaires des enseignants
c'est pas du
méprisant aujourd'hui les enseignants
dans la rue Benjamin Coriat rebondir
justement c'est super cette taxe sur les
super dividendes ils ont pas
effectivement récupéré l'amendement le
gouvernement ils auraient dû aussi vous
penser non mais si
il y a un truc qui est absolument pas
possible un truc qui est absolument pas
possible qui est que
lorsque il y a un coup de tabac on va
dire le covid ou une hausse très brutale
de l'énergie etc il faut dépenser
davantage d'accord parce que parce que
sinon
après on peut discuter mais on sait
qu'il faut il fallait creuser encore le
défi
s'effondrer les entreprises et laisser
les salariés à mourir de faim pendant le
covid bon donc je veux dire il faut
continuer le poids qu'il en coûte c'est
ça non non je suis pas en train de dire
ça laissez-moi finir je suis en train de
dire on ne peut pas à la fois quand il y
a des coups de tabac dire il faut
dépenser plus et je suis je suis de
cette école oui bien entendu je veux
dire les politiques contracycliques on
apprend ça à nos étudiants de première
année bien et heureusement qu'on
continue à leur apprendre bien et dans
le même temps lorsque il y a des
aubaines dire ah non touche pas ah non
touche pas c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible ça veut dire que à partir du
moment où des gens comme Total font de
leur profit ce qu'ils font mais
attention dépassant le cas total il y a
eu 44 milliards de dividendes
en France au premier semestre 2022 on a
battu tous les records donc on peut pas
dire on aide mais quand il y a des
winfall profite on touche pas on ne peut
aider que si précisément
en situation de
profit exceptionnel on les utilise pour
combler les trous c'est tout à fait
impossible sinon par ailleurs non je
voudrais dire encore ça je voudrais dire
encore ça c'est winfall profite etc à la
fois ils viennent de la conjoncture mais
viennent aussi d'une politique
systématique qui va du cice à la
réduction des impôts de production à la
réduction de l'impôt sur les sociétés à
au bouclier fiscal donc ça fait ça fait
15 ans hein que il y a une technique
systématique en faveur des entreprises
donc maintenant que au moins pour
certaines d'entre elles elles peuvent
recontribuer allons-y enfin il y a pas
hésités
dividendes mais c'est ça rejoint
effectivement
on t'adopté des cet été sur les sur les
super profits juste sur les super
dividendes il faut quand même se dire
que c'est très très limité et que
peut-être que certaines entreprises
pourraient se dire que pourquoi nous
sanctionner pour une année on a décidé
d'augmenter parce que c'est quand même
très précis nos dividendes plus que de
que la moyenne pour finalement un
mauvais élève qui est total et peut-être
que sur les dividendes qui auraient
peut-être matière des mécanismes à
trouver c'est à dire conditionner le
versement les dividendes à des la
participation à l'intéressement pour les
salariés ou encore je sais pas de
l'investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables peut-être plus travailler
là-dessus ça voudrait qu'il faudra
quasiment un peu les entreprises
après effectivement sur les super
profits il y a clairement un effet
d'aubaine aujourd'hui et qu'elle a moins
un symbole et en plus enfin pour les
sociétés énergétiques une rente qui est
plutôt partie pour durer la crise en
Ukraine on imagine ne va pas s'arrêter
du jour du jour au lendemain mais
attention cela concerne très peu
d'entreprises et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
est en train de renaître cette idée de
réinstaurer une surtaxe de l'impôt sur
les sociétés comme la surtax Juppé en
1995 je crois qu'à l'époque c'était pour
financer enfin pour faire en sorte que
la France soit dans les clous puisse
entrer dans la zone euro et aujourd'hui
ce serait peut-être une idée puisque
c'est temporaire c'est lié à une
situation qui toucherait pour le coup
toutes les entreprises qui font des
bénéfices un Roselyne peut-être une
sorte effectivement temporaire celle de
Juppé peut-être que vous en souvenez
aussi de cette tax
pour les grévistes oui pour les pour les
les patrons peut-être pas
qui était d'ailleurs à l'époque 95
c'était le début du libéralisme
aujourd'hui qu'on dit qu'on est à la fin
d'une forme de de libéralisme voilà mais
c'est pas pour autant que ça apaise le
climat social mais sur les supers
profits notez que Emmanuel Macron
n'était pas pour évidemment parce que
tout ce qui est idée de taxer impôts
évidemment ça fait peur donc qui s'en
est chargé c'est
Ursula vanderlion lors de son discours
voilà où elle parle non pas de taxer
mais de Tribulus
donc arrive là la subtilité c'est à dire
que voilà ça ne porte pas le nom de
taxes ni d'impôts et c'est peut-être de
nature à faire fléchir Emmanuel Macron
qui dit bah c'est pas moi c'est l'Union
européenne alors justement l'Union
européenne ça pourrait être la solution
Benjamin cette contribution si j'ai bien
compris de recevoir une participation à
un et ça d'abord ça concerne que les
énergéticiens n'est-ce pas
si j'ai bien compris on n'est pas prêt
de l'avoir se mettre en oeuvre parce que
il y a encore toute une série d'accord
qui doivent être donnés et on sait qu'il
y en a qui sont opposés donc moi je
pense que oui ça serait bien que
l'Europe prenne des mesures compatibles
avec son mandat mais il y a beaucoup de
pays qui se sont pas embarrassés de
cette manière là et qui ont fait une
taxe sur lesquelles on avait parlé de la
Grande-Bretagne
l'Italie la Grande-Bretagne je veux pas
dire de bêtises il y en a encore deux ou
trois ans l'Espagne
la Grèce l'Allemagne donc
la pudeur de Macron c'est une manière de
botter en touche parce que ça ne ça ne
lui convient pas donc je veux dire il y
a pas ce gêner là dessus moi moi parce
que lui a toujours voulu mettre en place
une politique fiscale pour plus
d'attractivité de la France qui n'a pas
cessé de le faire c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué tout à l'heure mais si continue
même en période de profit amené par le
vent alors on sait plus du tout où on va
je voulais juste rajouter une chose
l'expérience de faire des prélèvements
exceptionnels ça a été fait sous Juppé
ça a été fait sous Jospin je veux dire
personne n'en est mort vraiment personne
n'en est mort est-ce que c'était si on
peut
oui l'humain c'est avec c'est avec ces
prélèvements exceptionnels déjà sur les
pétroliers que Jospin a fait sa
politique j'ai rien à voir les choses
pas je veux dire mais qu'il a fait une
politique de relance qui a marché qui a
marché il avait de la croissance
mais il a accompagné la croissance par
des prélèvements qu'il a réinvesti et je
veux dire il y a rien de il y a vraiment
rien pourquoi il n'a pas été réélu il a
pas été élu président de la République
moi j'ai mon idée là dessus s'il n'avait
pas pris l'ensemble des mesures
libérales qu'il a pris par ailleurs
probablement Le Pen aurait pas fait
cette percée je veux bien voir cette
discussion avec libéralisme social c'est
ça que vous dites oui social libéral oui
un mot justement sur le gouvernement
Jean Garry est-ce que justement il
pourrait faire volte-face là-dessus par
exemple
[Musique]
donc ça va changer la donne d'abord
est-ce qu'on peut avoir une récession et
de l'inflation toujours parce que
normalement récession ça veut dire on
baisse les prix mais oui non mais on
peut avoir une récession en fait
bien entendu mais on peut avoir ça sous
une forme renouvelée pourquoi parce que
le la flambe et les prix elle est pas
liée à un excès de demande comme comme
pour l'inflation habituelle c'est-à-dire
que quand il y a trop de demandes et pas
assez de bien bon on a on a une
inflation elle est elle est très bien
déterminée par les problèmes d'énergie
d'alimentation de désorganisation des
circuits internationaux c'est pas un
excès de lié à la guerre en Ukraine
notamment
donc il y a ça d'un côté et puis de
l'autre côté
donc ça c'est l'inflation et la
récession elle aurait lieu parce que et
elle va avoir lieu la seule question
c'est quelle est sa profondeur et sa
durée
dire moins d'argent dans les caisses
et qu'on produit moi non non pas du tout
elle va avoir lieu parce que après
pratiquement une décennie et demi
d'argent gratuit qui a permis à tous les
spéculateurs de la planète d'avoir de
l'argent gratuit pour aller spéculer en
bourse et gagner énormément d'argent ça
n'est plus possible parce que justement
on est en inflation et on peut pas
continuer à donner de l'argent gratuit
donc les banques centrales sont en train
de remonter progressivement leur taux
d'intérêt aux États-Unis d'ailleurs elle
les remontent relativement vite
relativement vite parce que ils ont des
problèmes d'inflation encore plus
sérieux que nous et ça ça va être
récessif
de banque centrale on a l'impression
justement que on va continuer à avoir de
l'inflation
et en gros ça va faire baisser la
croissance non mais attendez il faut pas
demander aux banques centrales plus que
ce qu'elles peuvent faire mais
la politique de de très bateaux
d'intérêt plus de rachats des dettes
d'entreprise pour les mettre etc ça a
incontestablement permis de passer
la dernière crise économique le seul
problème c'est que très probablement on
a mené cette politique trop longtemps
voilà et donc maintenant que on a
l'inflation plus et qu'il faut faire
une politique de auto d'intérêt on se
retrouve dans une grosse difficulté on
va écouter encore monsieur Véran
justement le porte-parole du
gouvernement sur cette question du 49-3
parce que ça aussi c'est une question
politique qui fait partie du débat à
l'Assemblée en ce moment
nous faut avoir adopté le budget dans un
délai donné ce qui veut dire que
logiquement la fin des débats sur la
première partie du budget c'est pour la
journée de demain donc on continue
pour demain probablement pour demain
j'imagine maintenant on verra comment
les débats évoluent dans la journée
d'aujourd'hui évidemment ça entraîne une
grogne de toutes les oppositions dépose
des amendements les amendements sont
refusés et derrière ça sera le 49-3 oui
mais j'ai envie de dire Stéphanie c'est
pas vraiment une surprise à 49-3 on en
parle depuis le dès le lendemain des
législatives c'est à dire pas de
majorité absolue donc majoritaire
relative donc forcément pour faire
passer des textes avec deux oppositions
très fortes et puis les LR qui savent
pas trop où ils habitent donc forcément
voilà c'est c'est moi moi je trouve que
le 40 of Thois c'est d'abord c'est un
droit constitutionnel donc le
gouvernement a le droit de l'utiliser
moi je trouve que ce qui est plus
embêtant c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est le MoDem qui n'a pas voté
dans le sens que vous voulez le
gouvernement l'amendement sur sur la
taxation des super dividendes c'est ça à
mon avis le fait politique je sais pas
si vous êtes d'accord avec moi
au sein de la majorité et c'est ça qui
existe ça veut dire que le modèle
que le gouvernement aurait bien aimé
traité comme un des godillots ben il se
laisse pas faire
exactement
de Renaissance
comme on le faisait du temps de français
jusqu'à la fronde les troupes sont mieux
tenus que du temps de François Hollande
il y avait une fracture honnêtement mais
historique au sein de du Parti
socialiste mais il y a quand même il y a
quand même une il y a une gauche de de
renaissance je le mets entre guillemets
mais il y a une gauche de renaissance et
le fait que ça soit le modem avec cette
gauche qui a proposé cet amendement et
que le gouvernement tende à ne pas le
retenir montre qu'il y a une fracture
qui a chose qui qui ne vont pas et moi
ce qui ce que je redoute un tout petit
peu sur c'est que au sein du
gouvernement l'impression que c'est la
ligne le maire qui est qui l'emporte de
plus en plus et c'est pas une ligne qui
est qui est c'est une ligne qui en
contradiction avec quoi à la ligne le
maire c'est une ligne de politique de
l'oral voilà c'est une ligne néolibérale
qui qui n'est pas qui n'est pas en
cohérence avec ce qui a été annoncé
parce que quand vous d'un côté vous
dites on va beaucoup plus être dans
l'ouverture on va tenir compte de
rapport d'effort c'est à dire qu'il y a
une majorité relative et qu'il est
nécessaire de trouver des appuis des
majorités stéréo comme le disait Michel
Rocard à son époque tantôt à gauche
tantôt avec les avec les LR on peut
essayer de trouver des des
accommodements je veux dire qu'il y a
peut-être une partie des députés de la
des gauches pas forcément la France
insoumise mais d'autres qui auraient pu
éventuellement voter cette amendement
avec avec le modèle vous voyez donc là
le fait de ne pas le retenir dans le
dans la loi de finances votée par 49-3
je pense que c'est à mon avis c'est
c'est le signal qui est le plus de ces
derniers jours qui est beaucoup plus
important que dans le fond le le 40 ans
que toi qui va devenir une forme de
voilà c'est c'est une formalité hein
il y a deux choses le 49-3 c'est
parfaitement constitutionnel bien sûr il
y a aucun problème il est encadré
beaucoup plus encadré maintenant on peut
utiliser que deux fois le chauffer
c'est pas pour rien qu'on en discute
donc la constitutionnalité c'est pas
c'est pas discutable bien entendu mais
ça pose problème pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que c'est l'indication que
il y a aucun compromis qui a pu être
passé permettant de l'éviter parce que
je pense que c'est y compris pour le
gouvernement c'est pas de gaieté de cœur
qui vont passer au 49-3 et donc ça pose
le problème de savoir comment on
gouverne lorsqu'on a pas une maladie bon
ça c'est et donc c'est le signal que
c'est un grand classique c'est le signal
que l'on sait pas faire hein puisque on
fait le 49-3 et ce qui est beaucoup plus
embêtant alors là je m'adresse
n'existe rien et donc à l'historien de
la République c'est que on ne peut on ne
peut l'utiliser plus qu'une seule fois
par quinquennat donc je veux dire c'est
one shot l'an prochain il se passe quoi
bon donc je veux dire c'est pas une si
bonne nouvelle que ça de dire oui à 49-3
utile 49,3 à l'époque justement de non
c'était pas c'était
bon donc c'était un mode de gouvernement
mais aujourd'hui c'est plus possible
donc d'autres problèmes derrière c'est
pour ça que si
deux fois par session parlementaire
une fois sur le budget une fois
sur un autre sujet mais une seule fois
sur parc session sur un autre sujet mais
c'est pour ça que je parlais de
révolution culturelle tout à l'heure
dans les entreprises il faut une
révolution culturelle aussi dans nos
usages politiques je veux dire que là on
voit très bien les blocages d'un côté un
gouvernement qu'il a hop montre sur ce
sujet précis de l'amendement modem que
il est intransigeant l'autre côté une
opposition qui elle aussi a priori dit
qu'elle ne va pas voter le budget avant
même qu'on puisse essayer de discuter on
est à rebours de l'esprit de cela dit
on est à rebours de
l'esprits
le cabinet de Matignon donc on sait
qu'il y a des discussions qui sont
intéressantes c'est pas bien voilà donc
il y a pas forcément des caméras
derrière mais
s'il passe le 40 euros ça veut dire
qu'effectivement on peut pas trouver
tout est percuté par des ambitions qui
sont à long terme d'ailleurs c'est
presque même déjà la présidentielle de
2027 tout ça donc la position des LR on
voit très bien qu'elle est complètement
contaminée par ça et pas seulement
d'Édouard Philippe et celle du MoDem on
voit bien que celle des chercheurs
pas seulement parce que la de
conflictualité de la France insoumise
elle est aussi à long terme donc tout ça
est percuté par des objectifs que
j'appellerai politicien et cette culture
du parlementarisme de la négociation
parlementaire qui est une culture
historique est complètement oubliée
aujourd'hui et je le déplore une
conclusion peut-être alors je sais pas
si on parle de question un budgétaire et
de ce fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
anti-inflation il va se poser
précisément la question de savoir
comment le financer à long terme dans la
mesure où la situation est partie pour
durer qui va falloir probablement
trouver on l'a dit de nouvelles sources
fiscales ou de nouvelles ressources et
peut-être qu'il va falloir et le
gouvernement en parle le fait pas encore
mais commencer à cibler ces aides qui
sont actuellement donnés à tout le monde
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat Karina Chabot roselynefeuvre merci
Benjamin Coria d'avoir été avec nous
merci Jean garrigue et merci à vous tous
d'avoir suivi vous restez avec nous
surprend pas 4